so our path starts in 2017 with the
release in four browsers of webassembly
1.0 and we called it the MVP short for
minimum viable product because there are
still a lot of work left to do it was
definitely minimal so we collected a lot
of these remaining features to be done
and published this post MVP roadmap Lynn
Clark made this really cool video game
like skill tree diagram showing how the
different features unlock different use
cases indeed a whole bunch of this work
has been in progress in the web assembly
CG extending the core of webassembly
with new instructions and value types
but if we look at this one branch of the
skilled tree and then zoom in
it says portable interface so so what's
that about
so in general if we want to have
portable programs we need a portable
instruction set and a portable system
interface
now in the browser of course webassembly
is that designed to be that portable
instruction set and JavaScript and the
web platform are a natural portable
system interface
but if we want to run webassembly
everywhere then well what takes the role
when we don't necessarily have
JavaScript or the web platform
so to answer this question we started
the Wazi subgroup wazzy for standing for
webassembly system interface
but that immediately raised the question
well like what sort of system are we
even interfacing with here one is not
just generically interface with systems
and from you know experience we had this
high level goals of we wanted
capability-based security and modularity
so we went about kind of learning about
the background doing background research
and seeing what work had already be done
had already been done that we could
learn from
so in the direction of capability-based
security a great resource is Mark
Miller's dissertation on robust
composition and the takeaway here for me
was that capabilities by it's not just
security which is kind of like eating
our vegetables and that it's good for us
and eventually grow to like it but also
composability which is like the fire
flower that makes us like fire Mario and
uh productive so that was exciting
uh and we also you know did some
research in the modularity directions
around the ml module system and the work
on units and the high level takeaway
here is that complex modular
applications need what I'm going to call
parametric linking and I'm going to talk
more about later
and then combining these as a bit of
research on the wyvern language which
kind of really nicely Illustrated how
capabilities can go really well with
parametric linking so excited by all
this we published and collected all
these ideas into this nanoprocess Vision
blog post which kind of painted this
picture of a bunch of really
fine-grained nanoprocesses that
encapsulate their memory and are trading
fine-grained capabilities between each
other
and then uh and then there is a bunch of
quiet so
um so sorry about the delay there
um
there was a whole um pandemic you know
and that you know didn't help that a
customer must have to switch employment
situations but uh but in general like
just digging into this nanoprocess model
like asking like well what concretely is
this box it's a it's a hard question
so you know a reasonable reply is well
why not just use a wasmified posix
process and indeed if you look at the
picture it says quasics because that's
where we started because it makes sense
that's uh you know we start with Cloud
API and because posic has a lot of what
we want it has encapsulated low-level
States cross-language interop
unforgeable capabilities and lots of
code that we want to use and spoiler
alert don't worry we will
so is that just it do we just take posix
and stuff it into wazzy and then you
know mission accomplished well let's
let's you know take a step back and say
first why are people putting wasm into
production
so you know there's some obvious reasons
like language Independence has an open
formally defined portable standard a
strong sandbox-based security
and then maybe we could ask is it are we
trying to run the same CLI tools the
same way just out with wasm as our
instruction set or are we trying to run
the same containers the same way just
now with wasm as the instructions said
and you know you could and you know
definitely people have played around
with it but that's that's not what's you
know motivating us as much as taking the
next steps smaller in the progression
from VMS to containers to webassembly
or serverless execution with ultra fast
cold start and ephemeral lifetimes and
so getting back to our previous question
just do posix would work pretty well you
know here but for these more futuristic
use cases we ran into trouble and I'll
summarize this with four high-level pain
points and then four proposed design
Alternatives that uh that we worked on
so our first pain point is linking via
the file system
so a common experience I think here is
you have some software components and it
seems like they should be interface
compatible so I should be able to like
Snap them together and build this like
Tower of beautiful software that I have
in my mind
but the reality is like less pretty and
involves a lot more glue code and the
reason is that in addition to these
explicit interfaces we've got this file
system here that everything is kind of
colliding and with each other and a lot
of that glue code is working around that
so we're proposing instead is called
parametric linking this is kind of from
this background research
and I'm going to describe in three steps
so first we distinguish units of code
which are static and immutable like the
stuff you'd store in a file
distinguish that from instances of the
code which are Dynamic and stateful and
the type of things you load in memory
and run
next we say that a unit of code declares
Imports that must be supplied when the
code is instantiated so for example my
awasm can have an import X of type
string and when I instantiated the first
time I have to supply a value for that
import X and when I substantiate it a
second time I can supply a different
value and get a different instance
and then lastly we allow units of code
to instantiate other units of Code by
supplying their Imports
so I've got my a.wasm and I can have a b
dot wasm that Imports an instance of a
and then C has the flexibility if it
wants to to say when you instantiate a c
first make one instance of a in an
instance of B linked to that's in a
second instance of a and a second
instance of b-linked to that
and while many module uh and package
systems have something like Imports
often called dependencies
fewer have this ability for code to
instantiate other code although
increasingly some do like react
components or terraform parameterized
modules and so we're kind of going with
that trend
and so concretely what this enables
things like mocking and local testing
without needing a dependency injection
framework
dependency resolution without lock files
at runtime
and service chaining without having an
intervening Network stack
so our second pain point is complex data
passed as unstructured text
so a common experience here I think is
I've got a programming it you know spits
out some Json I'd like to feed it into
the second program and ideally it would
take the same Json but in practice you
know often it'll just take its own
random thing because it can parse its
own arbitrary input format so I have to
write some glue code to adapt between
the two and that's a composability pain
point
and next I have to program as to do all
this work stringifying the Json and
program BS to parse its input format and
so that cost performance and in this
nanoprocess model we have lots of itty
bitty nanoprocesses this can add up to a
significant percentage of the overall
time
and lastly let's say program a has a
file descriptor pointing to a resource
and it wants to pass it over to program
B it could use in like out-of-band Unix
domain sock and send message but that's
kind of a pain and so mostly we don't do
that instead what we do is you stick the
resource in a whole file system give it
a file name have both programs import
the whole file system and that allows us
to pass the file by its file name in the
Json and this is an example of a pattern
that colleague Dan Gomen calls ghosts
and he has a great blog post explaining
kind of how all the problems and pain
points that arise when you have ghosts
in your programs and more generally the
fact that program A and B import a whole
file system just to pass a file as an
example of excess Authority
so instead we're proposing to have high
level value types
so we start with value types like
strings lists records variants and add
subtyping so my program a can put out an
abstract record with two fields and
program B can take the same record or a
subtype for example here with an
optional extra field
which is allowed by subtyping which
allows us to evolve our interfaces over
time
next we make reading and writing these
values in and out of linear memory
configurable yet optimizable so
programmagas to specify how those bits
turn into the abstract record and for
example gets to choose the string
encoding whether it's utf-8 or utf-16
and program b gets to make the opposite
decision
and then because an aot compiler can see
how these things are configured it can
compile this down to do a direct copy
and transform directly from A's linear
memory into B's linear memory
and lastly we allow value types to
contain opaque handles
so for example program B can accept like
a picture field via a handle to a blob
not copying the contents of The Blob but
passing just a handle to it but that
does raise the question well we'll
handle to what where did blob come from
is it like just magically built into
system
and this gets to our next pain point
which then positives everything is a
file descriptor
so if I have two programs and a bunch of
high-level interfaces they might want to
use I say like program B let's say uses
these interfaces and or programmazes
these ones and program B uses these
other interfaces when I compile it all
down to posix executables they kind of
look the same they both just use file
systems and sockets and so when I look
at them from an external perspective I
just say like these these have the same
interface I can't really tell the
difference from the outside and this is
from the perspective of say a dependency
auditor trying to understand risks
supply chain attacks virtualization
tooling trying to run programs and other
scenarios and they were compiled for
and a runtime orchestrator who's you
know orchestrating over distributed
heterogeneous networks saying where can
I run this program
so instead we're proposing this to have
resource and handle types
and we do this by first decoupling
resources which are non-copyable things
with lifetimes
handles which are values that point to
resources
and then functions that take and return
handles and operate on resources
next we say that resources have a
resource type and handles have a handle
type that specifies a resource type so
for example I can have a resource type
blob and a function that takes a handle
to a blob or two resource types requests
and Fields and a function that takes a
handle to request and returns a handle
to its fields
and lastly we say the resource types are
runtime type tags that can be imported
created and exported
so my program a can import the resource
type blob and program B can import the
request and field resource types and
importantly they look different from the
outside I can say without looking at the
code program a is working on blobs and
program B's working on HTTP requests
and what this enables
is things like layer 7 interfaces that
avoid sidecar protocol parsing overhead
so for example if two programs want to
pass a request between them they don't
have to serialize it to a socket just to
deserialize it on the other side things
pass the handle across the boundary
we can have resources that are directly
usable without manual glue code
and we can have virtual platform
layering which is something I'll return
to at the end
and our last pain point is low-level
concurrency
so if I have two processes they both
start with a thread because every
process starts with a threatened posix
and that means for them to communicate
with each other they have to do thread
synchronization and then maybe that's
not a lot of overhead if I have a few
monolithic processes but in this
nanoprocess Vision where I have lots of
tiny little processes this can add up
and add a lot of scheduling overhead
so that's a performance pain Point next
if I want to do concurrent i o I can use
multiple threads to do multiple blocking
requests but now I'm doing
multi-threading which is hard and if you
can't see this is a picture of a famous
Mozilla hacker David Barron who had used
to have a sign famously that you can see
in the top left top left that says Must
Be This Tall to write multi-threaded
code because it's hard and ultimately
leads to less composable components now
I don't have to do multi-threading
instead I can be using concurrency
mechanisms like select an e-pole but
these are rather coupled to the built-in
resource types of the operating system
and harder to make work with these
user-defined resource types that we were
just talking about
and additionally I want to use these
from a source language that means
writing a lot of high-level glue code to
manually bind it so all these low-level
concurrency mechanisms which is a
language interop pain point
so instead what we're proposing is to
have future and stream types where we
say that calls between instances can
share a stack so for example if I have
two instances linked together and the
host calls G I can be pushing frames on
the stack and then when I2 calls into i1
through F I can just keep pushing frames
on the stack sharing a stack and an
operating system literature this is
called thread migration and it's an
optimization to avoid cross process
overhead which is effectively what we
want here
but additionally a colleague can suspend
itself allowing the caller to make
progress so I one can suspend itself
returning control flow to I2 which keeps
running holding a handle to the
suspended f-task
next we add future and stream types for
passing returning these handles to
suspended tasks
so I could have a fetch function that
returns a future response or more
generally a merge function that takes a
list of Futures and returns a stream
and lastly we Define a low level control
flow protocol for futures and streams
that language runtimes can integrate
with so if I have three different
instances linked together compiled from
three different languages they can have
their three separate async runtimes
compiled inside of them and they work
together because they're all speaking
the same low level control flow protocol
with the async runtimes integrating kind
of like with kind of like they integrate
with an operating system
and what this enables is efficient bulk
data streaming into and out of gas and
linear memory async interfaces that are
directly usable without manual glue code
and defining and enforcing
cross-language structure concurrency
which is a whole separate topic I don't
have time to get into but it's enabled
by the high-level nature of Futures and
streams
so putting this all together we started
with posix which defines IO with the
outside world and also a process model
we identified four pain points with the
process model and four design a proposed
design Alternatives so kind of
Performing that substitution is the
component model and it's layered on top
of webassembly core webassembly
providing the portable instruction set
that we can now bundle up into these
abstract black box reusable units of
code and this frees up Wazi to do what
is originally designed to do which or
started to do which is Define IO at the
outside world being layered on top of
the component model and being able to
Define modular interfaces for all the
sorts of things like login config file
system sockets grpc and all that
so the component model is what we've
been spending a lot of time factoring
out of wazzy now if you've been around
the block a few times you might be
saying right now like components OMG not
korba again
or Java ee or MSD com right because
we've seen this before and there's a lot
of differences that could be pointed out
enough to fill the whole talk but the
big one I'd like to point out is that
distributed computing is out of scope
for the component model
this means partial failure persistence
live upgrade scalability and
availability these are definitely
important problems but they're not
something we can automatically solve in
the component model instead we're just
leaving these up to a higher layer like
the platform embedding and future higher
level specifications
so what's the developer experience look
like for all this
so a good starting point is to say that
components are sort of like the love
child of two things we're familiar with
on the one side Source language modules
like JavaScript modules where we're
doing fast sync and async calls to other
modules through imports and exports
and microservices defined by via IDL
like open API or grpc where we're
defining shared nothing interfaces in an
IDL and deriving our language specific
bindings from that
so that raises the question well what's
the ideal for components and that's
something that the lazy subgroup has
been working on for a while and it's
called wit so just showing whip by way
of Abridged wazzy examples
whereas he could Define a wazzy CLI main
interface that defines a main function
that takes an arc V list of strings and
a standard N is a stream of chars where
it turns standard out as a stream of
chars
I can define an interface logging back
end that defines a log function that
takes a log level and two strings
Define a Wazi file system interface that
defines two resource types for
directories and files in the operations
that are appropriate on them and then
totally separately we can define a wasi
HCB types interface that defines a
totally disjoint set of resource types
for appropriate for HTTP things like
Fields body requests and responses
and then building on that HTTP types
interface we can define a Handler
interface that defines a handle function
that takes a request and returns a
future response and a whole bunch more
interfaces like that and hopefully the
picture you're getting here is that
these interfaces can be small and
modular and focused on just one task
but then from a component author
perspective I'll have to ask the
question like which interfaces can I use
like all of them I mean that sounds nice
but like I'm a little skeptical that I'm
going to get a GPU or neural network
Hardware everywhere
and then from a platform vendor's
perspective I asked the same question do
I have to implement all these interfaces
and that's a much scarier proposition
because there's like a lot of them and
they're going to be growing over time
and not even possible to implement in
all places so we're missing one more
thing to kind of Link these together or
answer these questions and that thing is
being actively worked on it's and it's
called worlds
so just to show Worlds by wave example I
Define a world where called wazzy CLI
command that kind of captures a
traditional posix environment where I
get to import a logging back-end as my
console and a file system and sockets
and then I export a main function that's
like a traditional kind of posix view of
the world
but separately I could have a wazzy HP
proxy world where I get to import a
console so here we're using the same
interface so interfaces don't care which
world they're used in they can be used
by multiple worlds
but instead of a file system in sockets
I'm importing an upstream Handler and a
config configuration values and instead
of exporting main I'm exporting an HTTP
Handler interface
and here we can see the same Waze HP
Handler interface used as both an import
and an export because interfaces don't
care they can be imported or exported
and this is critical for virtualization
which we'll get to in a bit
so in general we're gonna have Bunches
of interfaces growing over time
and then worlds kind of Select subsets
of these interfaces that are imported or
exported in a certain context so I
showed these two but you can imagine a
whole bunch more like a database
user-defined function or a cloud service
world and a bunch more
and because these worlds are set like we
can say things like the HP proxy world
is included in the cloud service world
or we can Define HP caching proxy world
that extends an HTTP proxy with a cache
we can Define things like unions and
intersections on worlds
so from a platform vendor perspective I
support a world by implementing its
Imports and calling its exports and then
duly from a component author perspective
I Target a world by calling its Imports
and implementing its exports
and thus a world is sort of like a
higher order interface that sits in
between platform vendors and component
authors
okay so I have a world now what can I do
with it so let's take our example HTTP
proxy world
there's a new tool that's being worked
on the bytecode alliance called with
binding and whitbungin gives you a set
of choices the first one is are you
making host bindings or guest bindings
if I go the guest Direction my next
question is well what guest language are
you using and there's a bunch of
languages in progress more than I'm
showing here including python go and
Java and c-sharp I'm going to show Jason
rust so if I go the rest Direction with
bindgen Will generate some Rust glue
code and this glue code will allow me to
write idiomatic nice kind of looking
rust code like in this white box like a
handle function that takes a request it
calls the log before passing on the
request to the Upstream and I compile
all the stress codes some core wasm and
feed that into a second tool being
developed in the bycode lines called wit
components wit component will bundle up
this corwasm along with the high level
types in the original World to create a
self-contained self-defining component
in a binary format defined by the
component model
now if I back up and go the Jazz
direction that will generate some js
engine glue code which will allow me to
write some idiomatic looking JS code
where I get to use JS Imports to import
the worlds Imports and write JS exports
for World exports and when I compile
this to core wasm and feed it to wit
component I'll get a component of the
same shape and type as the rust
component just different guts
and some from a guest perspective what
width and wit component tooling give us
is sdks make easy
now if I go the host Direction I'll
again have the same language choice if I
go the rest Direction what that will do
is wrap wasm time with some glue code
that gives me safe high-level traits
that I Implement for imports and call
for exports and into this I can plug in
reusable implementations of common
standard Wazi interfaces or just my own
custom implementations
and then this wrapped was in time will
be able to run the components that I
compiled from the same world or any
compatible world
now in theory I shouldn't need the
host.js direction because the goal is
that the components will be native
Implement will be natively implemented
by JS runtimes just like corwasm is
today but until then
the host gesturex will give us a
polyfill that allow us to run components
in today's JS engines and browsers as
wasm 1.0 and JS glue code
so from a host perspective what wit
gives us is embedding made easy and I
get all of this from just the cost the
low low cost of one world
so that's the tooling that's in progress
now the next step in tooling is around
virtualization so to motivate this we've
got tons of posix programs that are
already written today and they use libc
and file systems and sockets
and the so these implicitly Target the
wazzy CLI command world that I showed so
that's what I have but let's say I want
to run this code in a cloud service
world
so how do I do that well I can start by
compiling my code to a components and
because it targets the CLI command world
I'm going to get a component that
Imports a file system and exports a main
interface
and now I want to wrap this in a
component that does Target the cloud
service world and to do that I'll use
some tool that I'm going to call
virtualize commands now it doesn't exist
today but the idea is not new this is
effectively what M scriptton's virtual
file system does in wazy VFS do today
and its inputs would be a configuration
file that says how do you want me to
virtualize this file system and I could
say things like well in the blobs
directory I'd like to mount a blob store
and the assets director I'd like to
stick some data some assets stored as
data segments and virtualize command
will then produce will synthesize some
adapter modules that will be linked with
my original components to implement the
cloud service world
and all this is linked together using
that parametric linking feature that I
talked about earlier and what this means
is I can ultimately produce a single
component that runs on a cloud service
so the cloud service world doesn't know
anything about the CLI command World it
kind of just works
and this specific example is a an
example of a more General pattern that I
think we're going to see over and over
called virtual platform layering where
we Define a guest World which is what we
expose to our customers so they'll be
deploying components that run on our
platforms targeting this guest world but
then as an implementation detail we can
have a host world that has a totally
different set of imports and we
implement the guest World in terms of
the host world
and when we link all this together with
parametric linking this can run on a
host runtime that only knows about the
host world and what this allows us to do
is reduce the size of the trusted
Computing base and also decouple our
guest World from our host World allowing
us to evolve the host World kind of as
our platform evolves
and even Wilder is that this host World
itself could be a guest world of some
platform layer down which is what you
see when you have like large Enterprises
that have separate application and
platform teams or when we have companies
building platforms layered on top of
other companies platforms and so it's
important that the component models
support this all directly and
efficiently
so zooming way back out I think the big
picture here is we're bootstrapping
owassim meta ecosystem where we start
with platforms that are choosing wasm
for its unique qualities
and this attracts an initial set of
developers who are choosing wasm to run
code where they couldn't otherwise
and this causes us to build a set of
reusable tools that enable a first wave
of languages and apis but because these
tools aren't coupled to just one
platform they're kind of General using
the component model we can now attract a
new wave of platforms who are now
tapping into this meta ecosystem getting
a bunch of stuff they didn't have to
build themselves which can attract a big
newer wave of developers who are now
choosing wasm for its like ease of reuse
and productivity in all these reusable
components
and then this can cause us and lead us
to build a whole new wave of tooling
that allow us to compose applications
out of components and a whole new kind
of developer programming models
and at this point time will be fully
fully booted and having a good time
so what's the status of this all
well there's a formal specification in
progress with an operational semantics
reference interpreter and reference test
Suite
large parts are already implemented in
wasm time with bindgen and wasm tools
there's an upcoming Milestone called
sync components with full parametric
linking value resource and handle types
aimed for q1
and then after that the big milestone is
adding future and streams so the async
support to the component model
with the hard which is going to be hard
but it's going to factor out a bunch of
otherwise duplicated necessary work
and then some final bits to close out a
component model MVP for example optional
imports and exports
so that's it um here's a bunch of links
for if you're excited and you want to
get involved you can get involved in the
standards there's regular meetings and
here's a list links to proposals that
you can kind of track the standards
proposals on here's links to there's
regular Wings Around wasm time and bind
gen tooling and there's a general bike
online to do a chat so thanks